seulement deux jours d'application
l'arrêté préfectoral du 19 août rendant
obligatoire le passage du ter dans les
grands centres commerciaux des yvelines
a été suspendu par le tribunal
administratif de versailles
l'arrêté litigieux qui restreint l'accès
de manière globale ne fixe pas des
conditions garantissant l'accès des
personnes aux biens et services de
première nécessité
quatorze centres étaient concernés sur
tout le territoire les chinois tous deux
plus de vingt mille mètres carrés un
arrêté mal acceptée par les
professionnels haoues fils vélizy 2 17
agents de sécurité étaient mobilisées
depuis deux jours sur les douze portes
d'entrée une enveloppe estimée à 130
milles euros pour le mois d'août j'ai
enregistré une baisse d'activité de 25 %
25 % de flux de clientèle en moins c'est
colossal on vient vraiment fragile et
les commerçants qui sont déjà à bout de
souffle après un an et demi de crise
nous avons un avantage d'être très grand
don airey capteur de co2 agents de
sécurité sens de circulation masques
dans les colonnes de nos confrères du
parisien la préfecture des yvelines
indique prendre acte du jugement
le passé ni terre ne sera plus exigé
dans ses centres commerciaux et ce
jusqu'à nouvel ordre elle étudie
toutefois l'opportunité de saisir le
conseil d'état